do you know in business it's always been
difficult to set the right price for
goods or services
everything is dynamically priced these
days whether it's a movie ticket a
flight ticket a hotel room or a cafe
predictive analytics is a common tool
business is used to target customers and
improve operational outcomes predictive
analytics is widely used in various
industries like marketing manufacturing
real estate healthcare and many more in
order to predict future outcomes using
regression analysis forecasting consumer
behavior is the best use case for the
predictive analytics using regression
analysis model in the real world
hey everyone i am mayank from simply
learn in this video we will learn what
is machine learning followed by machine
learning types we will continue this
session by understanding what is
supervised learning followed by its
types moving forward we will look at
what is regression analysis we will
continue this session by understanding
why we need regression analysis
after that we will look at the
advantages and disadvantages of
different types of regression analysis
models
further we will also see some popular
regression analysis algorithms in detail
followed by application of regression
analysis after discussing regression
algorithms we will see a hands-on live
demo using olympic 2022 data set and how
regression algorithms work at last we
will end this video by discussing job
opportunities in regression analysis
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel hit the
subscribe button and please don't forget
to press the bell icon so you will never
miss any update from simply learn
also if you are willing to upskill
yourself in machine learning check out
our free course on machine learning by
skiller check the link in the
description below
so without any further ado let's begin
machine learning is a subpart of
artificial intelligence the art of
making computers learn and act like
human by feeding data and making
prediction based on experience for
example by using ml algorithms you can
determine the quickest route with the
least amount of traffic arrival time the
pickup location and the best optimal
part to the destination
machine learning is classified as
supervised learning unsupervised
learning reinforcement learning semi
supervised learning after understanding
what is machine learning and its size
let's understand what is supervised
machine learning
in supervised machine learning machines
are trained using label data also known
as training data to predict results here
label data refers to a group of data
tagged with one or more names and the
data is already known to the machine
in the real world supervised machine
learning can be used for image and
object recognition predictive analytics
customer sentiment analysis spam
deduction and many more
provides machine learning can be further
classified into two problems which are
classification and regression let's
quickly understand them one by one
classification is a process in which new
observations are recognized and
separated in a such a way that they can
be categorized
a classification algorithm is trained to
identify the spam emails by studying the
difference between spam and non-spam
email a function that converts an email
text into a categorization for spam
could serve as a classification model or
non-spam classification
there are some popular classification
algorithms that come under supervised
machine learning are random forest
decision tree logistic reaction k
nearest neighbors and many more the next
one we have is regression
regression algorithm is used to find out
the connection between dependent and
independent variables dependent
variables are nothing but a variable
that we are trying to predict or
forecast and independent variables are
the factor that influence the analysis
it is usually used to make projections
medical researchers frequently utilize
linear regression to study the
connection between patient blood
pressure and dosage researchers may give
patients different quantities of a
specific medication and track the how
their blood pressure changes a
regression model might use dosage as a
predictor variable and blood pressure as
a response variable
there are some popular regression
algorithms that come under supervised
machine learning
first one is linear regression
regression trees non-linear regression
bayesian linear regression
after discussing what is supervised
learning and its types let's move
forward to see what actually regression
analysis is
a stat technique known as regression
analysis is used to simulate the
relationship between dependent and
independent variables using one or more
independent variables regression
analysis more precisely enables us to
comprehend and when other independent
variables are held constant
changes in the dependent variables value
that correspond to an independent
variables are changing
prediction include values that are
continuous or real such as temperature
age pay and cost
there are some following concept or
terminologies that must be understood in
order to completely grasp regression
analysis the first one is dependent
variable in a regression analysis the
primary variable we wish to predict or
comprehend is the dependent variable
here dependent variables are also known
as target variable the next one is
independent variable
the term independent variables also
known as predictor refers to the
elements that impact the dependent
variables or are used to forecast their
values
and the third one is outliers
an observation that is extremely high or
extremely low in relation to the other
observed values is referred as an
outlier an outlier should be avoided as
it might affect the outcomes
the fourth one is multicollinearity the
situation is set to as occurring when
independent variables have a higher
correlation with one another than other
variables it shouldn't be included in
the data set because it causes issues
when determining which variable has the
greatest impact and the fifth one is
overfitting and under fitting
overfitting is the problem that occurs
whenever system problems work well with
the training data set but poorly with a
test data set under fitting is the term
used when an algorithm does not perform
well even with attaining dataset after
understanding what regression analysis
is and its terminologies let's move
forward and see why we use regression
analysis
including those involving the weather
sales marketing trends and other factors
in this situation we need regression
analysis that can make forecast more
precisely so let's understand the
concept of regression analysis using an
example
business frequently used linear
regression to understand the
relationship between advertising
spending and income for instance they
might run a simple linear model with
advertising as a response variable and
revenue as a predictor variable the
regression model would look like this
the van equals to beta0 plus b1 ad
spending where there are no
advertisement the coefficient zero would
indicate the whole expected revenue
when advertising expenditures are
increased by one unit coefficient will
represent the typical change in the
total revenue that is one dollar if beta
1 is negative then higher advertising
expenditure will result in lower revenue
if beta 1 is nearly 0 advertising
expenditures have little impact on
revenue and if beta 1 is positive it
would imply that more advertising
expenditures are linked to higher income
the amount of beta 1 will determine
whether a corporation decides to or
decrease its advertising budget
regression means creating a graph that
connects variable the best fit the given
data point the regression analysis model
can then make prediction about data
using the plot
regression analysis is defined as
showing a line or a curve that goes
through all the data points on the
target predicted graph in such a way
that vertical distance between the data
points and the regression is smallest
whether a model has captured a strong
link between determined by the distance
between data points and the line
there are some more use case of
regression analysis like we can use
temperature another variable to predict
or forecasts in regression analysis can
be used for identification of market
trends
for predicting traffic accidents caused
by reckless driving we can use
regression analysis for the same and
many more
so by understanding why we need
regression analysis moving forward let's
see some popular regression algorithms
in detail
the first one is linear regression
linear reaction is one of the most
famous and state forward machine
learning algorithm utilized for
predictive analysis linear regression
shows the linear connection between
dependent and independent factors the
line of the equation is y equals to m x
plus b here y stands for the response
variable or a dependent variable whether
x is for the predictor variable or an
independent variable here m is the
estimated slope and b is for the
estimated intercept
and the next one is regression trees a
regression tree is work through a cycle
known as binary recursive which is
iterative interaction that divides the
information into segments or branches
and afterward keep splitting the data
into smaller group as the technique
climbs each branch this tree is used for
the dependent variable which continuous
values for example a regression tree is
named food which is divided into
segments wedge and non-veg further it
keeps splitting into smaller groups
and the third one is non-linear
regression
nonlinear exertion is a type of
regression examination wherein
information is to fit a model and
afterwards communicate it with the
numerical function simple linear
regression relates to factor x and y
with a straight line y equals to m x
plus b while nonlinear regression
relates the two factor in a non-linear
relationship non-linear regression can
be predict population growth over time
or the relationship between gtp and a
country's time and the fourth one is
bayesian linear regression the algorithm
is a way to deal with the linear
regression in which statical examination
is attempted inside the setting of
bayesian inference linear regression and
basin regression can generate the same
prediction and with the help of bayesian
processing we can retrieve the complete
variety of inferential solution instead
of a point estimate
after seeing some regression analysis
algorithm let's move forward and see
advantages and disadvantages of
different regression analysis
models and the first model is linear
regression model the advantages are work
valve is respective of data set size and
the second one is gives information
about the relevance of features and the
disadvantages are the assumptions of
linear regression and the next one is
polynomial regression
the advantages are works on any size of
the dataset and the second one is works
very well on non-linear problems and
disadvantages are we need to choose the
right polynomial degree for the variance
tradeoff
the next one is support vector
regression algorithms and the advantages
are easily adaptable works very well on
non-linear problems and disadvantages
are difficult to understand and not well
known and the next one is decision tree
regression
the advantages of decision trees are
no need to apply scaling and the second
one is works very well on both linear
and non-linear problems and
disadvantages are poor results on a
small little set and overfitting can
easily occur and the last one is random
forest regression the advantages are
powerful and second one is accurate and
disadvantages are no interpretability
and the second one is overfitting can
easily occur
after seeing advantages and
disadvantages of different types of
regression analysis model let's move
forward and see some applications of
regression analysis
the first one is forecasting regression
analysis is frequently used in business
to predict potential opportunities and
dangers for example demand analysis
predicts how many items a buyer is
likely to purchase demand however is not
only the dependent variables when it
comes to business much more than just
direct income can be predicted using
regression analysis and the second one
is capm capital asset pricing model the
linear regression model is a key
component of the capital asset pricing
model capm which determines the
relationship between an asset expected
return and the associated market risk
premium financial analysts typically use
it for forecast corporate return and
operational performance when doing
financial analysis and the third one is
comparing with competition it can be
used to evaluate how well a business is
doing financially in comparison to a
certain rival
it can also be used to figure out how
the stock prices of two companies are
related to one another this can be
extended to find the correlation between
two competing companies
it might help the company identifying
the factors affecting the sales and
contrast to the comparable company
these methods can help small business
succeed quickly within a short period of
time and the last one is identifying
problem regression is beneficial for
identifying incorrect judgment as well
as for providing factual support for the
management for instance a retail store
manager might believe that extending the
hours of operation will greatly increase
sales
after seeing application of regression
analysis let's understand the regression
analysis using the code
so now we will see hands-on live demo
using olympic data set 2022
so we will use support vector machine a
support vector machine is a well known
supervised machine learning model it is
utilized for both information
classification and regression it is
regularly utilized for the grouping
issues let's open jupyter notebook
so this is our command prompt and here
we will write jupiter
notebook to open jupyter notebook so
press enter
so this is the landing page of jupiter
notebook and here we will open one
python file
so this is how the jupyter notebook ui
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in mathematical functioning
so the first one is numpy so we will
write import
numpy as np
and press enter so numpy is a python
library used for working with aries it
also has function for working in the
domain of linear algebra and matrices it
is an open source project and you can
use it freely so numpy stands for
numerical python
so we will import the next library as
pandas so we will write import
pandas
as pd
so pandas is a software library written
on python programming language for data
manipulation and analysis
in particular it offers data structure
and operation for manipulating numerical
tables and time series
so
so after importing the libraries we will
move forward and import datasets so for
importing dataset we have to write data
data
equals to
pd dot
read
underscore csv
so
here we have to write our data set name
olympics from px2022.csv
so oh is capital
in my file so
i don't know what's going on
yeah perfect
so press enter so
here pd is for pandas library read is
used for the reading the data set from
the machine
and csv is used for
the
type of file which you want to read so
uh then we have to write data set data
to see our data so
press enter so this is how our data set
look like so for separating data like in
a proper row and column so we can use
here
s e p
equals to
this semicolon
so after this enter so this is how our
data look like
so this is 91 rows and 27 columns data
so
so moving ahead we will replace any
values like these and his values from
zero so we will write
here so we will write here data equals
to
data
dot fill and a
value
equals to zero
so
after entering we will write here data
and press enter now see just we have
replaced all ns with zeros for better
results
see
all zeros with an is here
and no n is here moving ahead now let's
see how our data look likes in pie chart
so we will write import some matplotlib
libraries so
we will write
import
math
plot lib
dot pi plot
as plt
so
matplotlib is a graph plotting library
in python that serve as a visualization
utility
matplotlib is our open source and we can
use it freely and it is mostly written
in python a few segments are written in
c and javascript for platform
compatibility so we will write here
some mail
at the leads
so what leads
i guess
athletes
sorry for that
athletes equals to
data
square brackets we have to write
men
a capital
at
least
so
dot
sum
so
after enterings we have to write some
school
email
underscore
athletes
first two
data
square bracket open we have to write
here we can write a woman
uh athletes
dot sum
so we have to write here figure
comma a ax
equals to plt
or subplots
the plots
so we have to write this
size
oh sorry
figure size
size equals to
we can here give 12
comma
6
so
so here subplots uh like a subplot is a
secondary strand
of the plot that is a supporting side
story for any story or the for the main
story
so
we will write here
ex dot
pi
for the pie chart and
some underscore mail
underscore
athletes
comma
right here some
underscore female
score
athletes
square bracket comma
text
props
equals to
tsct
for the color of woman equals to
w
so
like after entering
we have to give a legends a dot legend
so
come on so loc equals to
upper right
comma
title title equals to
gender
comma
maybe
ox and just go
to
anchor this is for just a change
equals to
we have to give here
one comma
like zero
comma zero point five
comma
so we will write here ax dot
set
title title
so
here we can give title like total
proportion
of
of male and female
athletes
so
after this
we can write plt dot show
we can here write plt dot show
and we will see now like how our
pie chart looks like so
so this is how our pie chart look like
so moving ahead let's see one more
visualization data with bar graph so
we will write here countries
countries equals to data
noc
you have to just write in
so we will write here
men
underscore
add lead
to data
so we will write here
man
question
data
women
add needs
we will
write ind equals to
np dot arrange
range
so we have to give a length
[Music]
okay
into
we will write 32 here so width we will
cool
which we will give maximum width we will
give it
it's your wish how much you will give so
here we will write figure
comma ax
goes to
elt dot subplots
subplots
figure
size
equals to
64 comma 16
oh we will write a x dot
bar
because we are creating bar chart here
so we will write
imd
this is
width
slash 2
comma man
leads
comma width
equals to
first we will write here bit again
equals to
man
perfect so
here again we will write x dot
but
indeed
plus
width
divided by two
comma man
at least
so
we'll write here
not man this time we have to write for
man
woman
so we will add comma uh we will give
birth
x dot set we have to set the y level and
the x label so first we will write
for the y level so
available so this is like
amount
comma
font size
equals to
40
so
af dot set
title we will write the title
[Music]
but we will give light title like me
and
female
at least
um
like we can guys different
different
countries
so comma
font size
equals to
one size equals to we will write 050
so
like this
so let's
set the x labels to
underscore label
sorry x label
so here we will write
countries
size
equals to
chalice 40
so ax dot set
underscore
x
ticks
and d
so we will write here ax dot set
underscore
x takes
x we have to write only tick
so labels
equals to 20
so
ax
dot
legend
drop
equals to
size
okay we have to give something like this
30
so
we have to write
plot
plt dot
acid setup
x
dot get
x
click labels
and
comma rotation
it equals to
45
so we will write here at j equals to
the right
and again comma
rotation underscore mode
equals to
encode
so finally the time has come to for the
plot
dot
sorry this is not plot this is plt dot
show
so
so
press enter
and so this is our
bar graph how it looks like
for the uh how many countries
we
take countries
almost
almost 32 countries
so this is our data for the 32 countries
so moving forward
let's train our data now to set test
equal to data
[Music]
like
plus 2 not equals to 0
so comma sample
1 equals to 5
so we will write j
equals to data set
not sorry data only data we have to
write data bracket data
okay
we have to write here
total
total
medals
just write the same
here we will write
drop
drop
we will write draw test
dot index
index so here we have to write
dot
so
here we will write test
for testing data
and press enter so
this is our testing data so
this is how the data looks like
and now right for the train data so we
will write only train
then press enter so this is our training
data
so now we will import uh sc learn so we
will write
so
like scikit-learn sklen is the most
useful and the robust library for
machine learning in python so it
provides a selection of efficient tool
for machine learning and statical
modeling including classification and
regression so we will write import scipy
scipy
like from
sklearn
sql dot
svm svm is for sport vector machine
and import
sp r
so this is support vector regression so
we will write here
from
sklearn
dot
pre-processing
pre-processing we have to write import
standard
standard scalar
so
like we have to write here from
sklearn
dot model
let's go selection
selection
import
randomized
paste
search
cv
so let's get the our train data and the
test data so we will write this
scalar first to stand dot
killer
and
here we will write our test label
underscore x
equals to
scalar
okay my bad scalar
dot
fit
underscore
transform
test
it tests here to brackets and we will
write
athletes
so comma
and
woman
so here we will write for the test
y-axis
question
test
code
and the third one is
okay
noc
train
underscore x
equals to
scalar dot fit
right like this
underscore transform for transforming
the data
so we will write train
same
athletes
athletes
chain
underscore y equals to
train
sorry train underscore y goes to train
gold
comma
silver
comma
launch
branch
of it
and
press enter so
now we will
build our model so we have to write svr
equals to
svr
like this
prms for parameters equals to
c
we will write
psi pi
dot
stats
expo and exponential for
scale
equals to
100
okay
we will use gamma
that colon
sci-fi
scale
equals to
0.1
and
okay okay
so
here we will add comma
and the last one like kernel
so
colon
dna
so
like this so press enter
so
iters equals to
50.
rs
gold
randomized
search
cv
vr
comma
params
comma
and underscore
either
[Music]
you have to write for
same fall silver and the bronze so we
can copy here and we can
paste it again we can paste here
so we will just change it and here's we
have to write
silver
here we have to write
after this
we have to write
rs
gold
dot fit
like now we will train
underscore x label
comma train
train
underscore y
for this is we will do for the
gold
so
so same we will train this for the
on this silver and branch so we can copy
here from the ctrl v
so just we will change here to silver
silver ears prongs here
okay sorry bones
here you will write bronze
silver
here we will write y underscore
gold
underscore
at
equals to
rs
sorry underscore
for
bold
dot
prediction
sorry predict
train
underscore x
so again
same for silver
and branch so we will change that to
silver
silver
[Music]
so
let's move our screen a bit
up
so
here we will write print
pd dot
data
frame
so list
goes sip
and we will write
y underscore gold
let's go ahead
y let us go silver
comma hat
okay i small
comma
y underscore
bronze
underscore at
we will write here print
print
train
underscore y
dot reset
underscore
index
drop
equals to
true here
so
f i g figure comma x
equals to
test and let's go
y dot
reset
and let's put index
oh
right here test
bad sorry sorry sorry for this we have
to write plt dot
subplots
the plots we will make three by one okay
so
here we have to write test underscore y
equals to
test underscore y
dot
reset
underscore index
so
we will write here drops
drop
equals to
true
so we will write here a
zero for zero axis
dot plot
so
y
underscore gold
underscore at
then again zero
[Music]
sorry
zero
and the color should be
color should be
let's take green
okay okay so
again ax
0
dot plots
dot plot
so here we will write
test
what the test data
test underscore y
square bracket we have to write gold
okay
so the color should be
color should be
blue let's see blue here
so we will add blue
and
we have to make for the same
for the silver and gold
brown sorry
so we can copy paste here and we can get
the different x's name
this will be two
so
we have to write
one
two
left right
silver
okay
here's
silver two
here we have to write
bronze
now press enter
so after pressing so our model
so this is how the sm regression look
likes so this is how we made
regression analysis using svm
so moving forward let's see some job
opportunities in regression analysis
an extremely potent statical tool
regression analysis can be used to get
inside into customer behavior corporate
operation and factor affecting profit
businesses can use linear regression
analysis to analyze trends and generate
estimate or forecast a product sale also
be examined while using regression
analysis for example mccain ericsson
india private limited advertising
company used linear regression to
determine if the money spent on
marketing or a certain brand resulted in
a significant return on investment
the benefit of regression analysis is
that it allows us to control the
variables that can affect sales while
also capturing the individual effect of
each marketing effort in the real world
situation several advertising campaigns
are active at the same time if two
campaigns are broadcast simultaneously
on radio and television a regression
analysis can capture both the individual
and the combined effect of running these
ads together the commercial impact of
regression analysis can really hold a
huge potential to generate significantly
high productivity growth
currently one of the field with the
greatest soul of growth is analysis
analyst engineers are in high demand
there are various job profiles like data
analyst market research analyst
performance as developer and many more
who are hired with a skill of regression
analysis and machine learning the
average salary of data analyst engineers
in india is 6 lakh per annum and the
annual base pay for u.s and data analyst
engineers is
69517
all ventures as of now have countless
uses in regression analysis which is the
fundamental inspiration behind why there
is an interest of occupation in that
build the growth in technology has led
to increasing demand for the
professional who can understand and use
vast amount of data companies like
salesforce google ibm and manimo are
constantly hiring analyst engineers
i hope you guys found this video
informative and helpful if you have any
doubts or feedback feel free to leave
them in comments below we will be happy
to help you machine learning is a
trending field with a bright future if
chosen has a career here is a machine
learning certification course by
simplylearn to become a certified
machine learning professional kindly
check the course detail from the link in
the description below if you like this
video please subscribe to our channel
and don't forget to hit the bell icon
thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here